Africa and specifically subsaharan
Africa will be the next set of Emerging
Markets after China and Russia and
Brazil start to slow and if you look at
the economies there uh they're growing
dynamically and yet there are
significant challenges so what I'd like
to do in the next few minutes is talk
about the opportunity that we see but
also the challenges that exist there and
how a company like novaris can help be
part of the
solution now before I before I do that
though I want to tell you a little bit
about me just to introduce myself this
was me in
1982 when I had hair uh so you know I
always talk about and think about my
experience when I was at Stanford
Stanford is a unique place it's a place
that will stay with you for the rest of
your life and it shapes what you become
and in in terms of what I did after I I
left Stanford I uh started my career in
consumer package Goods actually starting
at the Clorox company just up the road
in in Oakland in a marketing position
and moved my way up and eventually ran a
very large division at a pretty young
age of the HJ Hines company uh when I
was in Europe running Europe for Hines I
was asked by a large pharmaceutical
company to sit on their board and I
didn't know much about Healthcare but I
fell in love with it and wanted to find
a way to get into Healthcare so I
bridged my way from consumer packaged
Goods into Health Care through the
position that you see novaris consumer
health I joined as head of the
over-the-counter drug business so it was
a way to uh use my marketing skills for
over-the-counter drugs and get into
healthc care eventually ran the
pharmaceutical Division and then was
named CEO almost well about four and a
half years ago so I'm in my my fifth
year as CEO
now I want to start by talking about why
I believe investing in Africa is so
important and the um the the the video
that I want to show you that just takes
uh two minutes lays out some of the
issues from a health uh challenge
standpoint in particularly in subsaharan
Africa and also talks a little bit about
how a company like novaris can be part
of the
solution
oh
o
issues that are facing subsaharan Africa
and why there's also though a big
opportunity first is you've got a fast
and growing population I'll show you
some facts in a minute uh you also have
a growing economy these are economies
that are growing among the fastest in
the world yet there's still significant
unmet medical need so if you start with
the population and you look Africa has
about 1.1 billion people and it's
growing at about 2.2% so it's growing
faster than Asia uh which was a surprise
for many people and even faster well
definitely faster than Europe was
essentially flat also the population is
urbanizing very rapidly so there are
already 50 cities in Africa that have
populations over a million people and by
2030 we estimate that 50% of the
population is going to live in the
cities so what does that mean it means
that this population as it grows is
going to create additional challenges in
subsaharan Africa if you look at 2010
and 2050 over the next 40 years there's
going to be a rapid increase in the
number of 15 to 25 year olds which will
put pressure on the education system
it'll also put significant pressure on
the Health Care system and
jobs but the good news is that there is
huge upside in terms of of financial
growth in these countries Nigeria 170
million people with an economy that's
growing six to 7% per year there's
there's going to be rapid growth and
there's going to be the emergence of a
middle class that we're already seeing
it yet at the same time you've got this
Divergence of of of significant poverty
levels in Africa so you've got e the the
the promise of great economic Prosperity
coming over the next 20 years but you
also have income disparities that are
very very significant so what happens is
we know that when uh developing markets
around the world start to build middle
classes demand for Health Care increases
pretty significantly because as people
move into the middle class expectations
around Health Care increase as Nations
become wealthier they they tend to spend
more on health care and we project that
in the let's say even just the
pharmaceutical industry we expect double
digit growth U for the next 10 to 15
years in Africa but a lot of it is going
to be out of pocket because the
governments and the reimbursement
systems in Africa are nowhere near where
they are in Europe or in the US so
that's going to create also additional
pressure on the Health Care system this
outof pocket um Dynamic that's going on
another issue that we have to overcome
in subsaharan Africa is the inefficiency
of the supply chain so when a company
like novaris sells a product in into the
uh supply chain into a country and let's
say that price is an index of 100 you
can see that because of the complex
supply chain of getting that product to
the patients who need it through
wholesalers uh retailers and even Health
shops which are small um sometimes even
just kios that exists in rural parts of
subsaharan Africa you can pay three
times the the price that we have sold it
into the system so if you're in Nigeria
you can see prices that are actually
higher than in most parts of because of
this inefficient supply chain and I'll
talk to you a little bit about how we're
addressing that now when you think of
Africa and the health care needs right
now everyone thinks of communicable
diseases so Africa has only 15% of the
world's population but they have a very
large percentage of the world's
communicable diseases so over 90% of all
malaria cases are in uh Africa HIV AIDS
three4 but what's happening now is that
as the emerging middle class starts to
become wealthier and wealthier you have
a situation where noncommunicable
diseases are starting to increase at
pretty rapid rates so we think that over
the next 20 years we're going to
significantly have to address um those
commun non-communicable diseases such as
diabetes cancer and cardiovascular
disease now let me with that kind of as
a backdrop let me tell you about
novartis' approach and what we're what
we're doing and what we're taking and
I'd like to introduce the company just
for a couple of minutes and then talk to
it specifically about what we're doing
in Africa we have we are a company that
is based in Switzerland so we are a
Swiss company we have a very rich
Heritage and it's in our DNA to care for
patients people who come to novaris
whether you work in as a scientist or as
a physician or as a commercial person
they generally come to novaris because
they want to help patients that have
significant unmet medical need and we
Define our mission as caring and curing
and we measure the number of people that
we touch every year with one of our
medicines and last year this is an
audited number we hit 1.2 billion
patients um around the world it's partly
because of the diversification that we
we have for example our strategy is to
win through science-based Innovation so
we invest a significant amount of money
in Discovery and development at a time
when many pharmaceutical companies are
starting to Outsource R&D we're
insourcing R&D and that's the way that
we believe that we will move uh medicine
ahead in the next 20 years but it starts
with the patient need so we Define our
what we do as as thinking about the
needs of people that have health care
needs so people need Innovative
medicines new cancer drugs that can
change the course of a disease but
people also need prevention vaccines uh
they need affordable options like
generic versions of innovative medicines
so that we can increase access uh to
medicines in many countries and also
they need selfcare many many people
around the world are taking Health into
their own hands and many over the count
drug products will be able to help
people around the world care for their
own health so we have structured our
divisions we have five divisions they're
quite autonomous ranging from an
Innovative Pharma division to an iare
division a generics division a vaccines
Division and then a self-care Division
and each of them work together to try to
solve Health Care needs around the world
we're a very uh big company bigger than
what most people think our sales last
year were $58 billion we invest $9.9
billion a year in research and
development that makes us the seventh
largest company in the world in any
industry in terms of the amount that we
spend on research and development we are
one of the top 20 companies World in
terms of market capitalization we just
crossed $200 billion do so this is a
company that has significant resources
that can help solve solve uh Health Care
needs around the
world we're most known for changing the
practice of medicine in certain diseases
our most famous drug is called glec and
this is a drug for chronic myo leukemia
this was introduced in 2001 and it took
what was a death sentence if you were
diagnosed with chronic myid leukemia and
it turned it into a chronic disease so
we have people that have been on the
drug for 133 years they're leading
normal healthy lives they take one pill
once a day and we've been able to
transform that particular cancer into a
chronic disease we also introduced the
and discovered the first menitis B
vaccine so you might have heard that
there was an outbreak in Princeton and
there was an outbreak at the University
of California at Santa Barbara recently
and even though this vaccine is approved
everywhere in the world except the US
the government asked us to to to be able
to ship product in and we vaccinated um
students at both Princeton and were
about to vaccin at the University of of
Santa Barbara University California
Santa
Barbara now if the way that we think
about Africa is that I want to be the
leading Healthcare company in Africa by
2020 today we're number
three and we're going to do that not
just trying to drive a commercial aspect
but we want to become the leading
partner
for governments in Africa to
significantly improve health care uh for
a for the African population and there's
four ways that we're doing this we're
we're starting by building local talent
I don't believe that you can run a
business in Africa by sending in a xats
from either Europe or from the US we
have to find African talent build that
talent and build our business um uh
through that Talent the second way is
that we're improving access to medicines
so if you think about um malaria malaria
is a curable disease we have a drug that
cures malaria in three days yet there
are hundreds of thousands of children
that die every year from malaria so
improving access is the second big
priority the third big priority is that
we must build local capacity local
manufacturing and local R&D capab ility
that's because of that horrible supply
chain that you just saw that leads to a
tripling of prices of medicine because
of that supply chain so we have to go in
and we have to build our own supply
chain so that we can get those prices to
the patients down and then finally we
have to link corporate responsibility to
everything that we're doing I'll show
you what I mean in a minute now starting
with the first in terms of how are we
going to in the world build Talent that
can that can run uh what what will be a
significant business in Africa local
talent we've started a a collaboration
with um Stellenbosch University in Cape
Town and we've identified uh great
talent in Africa that um actually from
Nigeria from Kenya from Tanzania where
we're training these people in
leadership skills in analytics in
communication skills in general
management skills and those those um
young professionals will become managers
at novaris in those local markets and
help us build the business we're also
bringing them to our headquarters in in
bosel Switzerland and giving them
cross-divisional or cross functional
assignments so that they can see how a
company like novaris operates because
many of them have not been out of their
home countries uh ever and then we'll
send them back so they might come for a
six-month assignment or they might come
for a 2 year assignment and this is a
way for us to build our talent this has
worked with uh for us in uh many parts
of the developing world so we started
seven years ago with the novaris China
university and we have a novaris Russia
University and it's a way for us really
to build skill sets that we need to help
us run our business now the second area
is improving access to medicines this
was the strategy that will help us
deliver inexpensive drugs to those
patients in in Africa that that need it
we have a generics division called
Sandos it's number two generics company
in the world and it works very closely
with our efforts in Africa we're
establishing a registration process
where we can take every new drug not new
drug because it's generics but every
drug that the Sandos division has and
bring them to subsaharan Africa through
a registration process that's in the
right now in the process of of being
worked and you're talking about things
like antibiotics like anti-diarrheal
like um pain medication but this is
another way that if we increase access
we're going to be able to reach a lot
more patients in Africa the third
strategy that I talked about is to build
local capacity if we don't manufacture
our products many of them will be
generic products at first in Africa
we're never going to get the kind of of
cost structure where we can really make
an impact from a pricing standpoint in
Africa we're also working very hard to
establish research and development
activity there more on the clinical
development side where we can work with
hospitals in subsaharan Africa and train
Physicians to work with our drugs when
we interact with physicians at that
level we're able to significantly
increase their knowledge about uh
Innovative new drugs that are coming but
also generics that we're bringing onto
the market that they might not have seen
before so this is all about creating
that local capability for um that will
enable us to be an African company in
fact and then the fourth is all around
corporate responsibility I showed you
how there's a huge issue with
communicable diseases um right now but
also non-communicable diseases and so
corporate responsibility and doing what
we do without profit is very important
to help address some of the severe
Health Care issues in Africa and one
example of that is the novaris malaria
initiative this is one of the largest
access to medicines programs in the
world we have a drug called cartum that
I as I said in three days can cure
malaria but the issue is access it's how
do we get this malaria medicine into the
rural parts of subsaharan Africa so that
we can ensure that children are not
dying from a disease that is curable and
so every year we we produce and sell at
zero profit uh cartum about a 100
million doses a year is um what our
maximum capacity is and we reached 102
million doses not doses actually
treatment so they're three-day three-day
treatments and we have saved over a
10-year period a significant number of
lives this is a a responsibility that we
feel only novaris is uniquely positioned
to deliver because of the drug that we
have called kartum uh and it's something
that we've done uh over the many years
we also just entered into a
collaboration with malaria no more
because I think no single company or or
entity is going to be able to to get
malaria to where we need it to be
malaria no more is a group that does
public fundraising and you you can go
online and you can um donate uh
treatments to children so you donate and
for every I think it's every dollar for
a child if you are for 10 um dollars
that's a $10 treatment or you could
treat 10 children and we are donating up
to three million uh doses for free that
would match those and this is another
commitment that we have but really I
consider this this is critically
important but it also is philanthropy
and we're we're now thinking that we
have to move Beyond philanthropy there's
a second um set of programs that we have
at novaris as we think about Africa and
we call these programs social Ventures
and it's more than just philanthropy the
the thing about philanthropy is if I was
hit by a bus uh my successor might think
that the malar initiative is a good idea
or might think it's not a good idea in
terms of ways to spend the company's
money so the way to ensure
sustainability is to create a
money-making entity not a big profit
generating entity but something that
will make money so that it will be
sustainable and it will help the
infrastructure in the country that it is
designed to help and so we have a
program that actually started in India
uh and we brought it from India into
parts of subsaharan Africa and we're
starting right now in Kenya and um the
the way that it works is we take the
rural villages in Kenya and we divide
them up into cells and in each cell
there might be 50 Villages and in that
one cell will hire a health educator
novaris Health educator and a novaris
sales supervisor and those two people
will visit each one of those Villages
and the health educator will col will
announce that she or he is is um
providing a seminar on uh certain types
of Health Care in the town Village and
we get huge turnouts this is not rocket
science in terms of what they're
teaching they're teaching basic sanit
but we're we're getting very very large
turnouts and then at the same time we're
selling small pack sizes of some of our
drugs through physicians in the area and
usually the sales supervisor will come
with a physician that can prescribe
that that will enable us to uh increase
access at low price points uh small pack
sizes and it actually generates a very
small profit we then in turn hire more
people in the area rural villagers that
can help us move into the next cell and
this has proven in India to actually go
from three years of profit loss so we've
been losing money for three years to a
break even situation and then we're
plowing that profit back into the um the
system and that enables the
sustainability that I think will make a
significant impact on Rural subsaharan
Africa in terms of uh of overall health
care so at novaris we are committed to
developing as I said earlier new new
medicines that will change the practice
of medicine that's what this company is
all about but also we have a very very
deep commitment that to help improve
health in developing nations uh
subsaharan Africa is a big Target for us
right now but we do this in a way that I
think will be good for novaris and
novaris shareholders so we're able to
build a good business over time and at
the same time we're able to
significantly impact the health care
burden in in those countries so thank
you very much and I'd be happy to open
it up to
questions
yes you guys investing in that at all
and how do you see that changing we are
we we um we're right now working with
the Earth Institute Jeffrey Sachs have
you heard of of Jeff Sachs um and he's
he's got a program called the uh 1
million community health workers program
and we are working closely with him
we've donated money to help him uh bring
community healthcare workers that could
help substitute for the lack of primary
care um he has some incredibly powerful
research that shows that you don't
always need a full-blown physician uh
that if you can get community health
workers into some of those particularly
the rural areas you can have a
significant impact on healthare it's an
issue though you know as these
governments start
to um have their economies grow they're
going to be faced with a lot of
different priorities right you saw the
the the way that the population is the
very young population they're going to
have to choose is this am I spending on
education am I spending on health care
so I think this is going to be a
long-term program but it's definitely an
issue
yes the second one is hepatitis I mean
preventable DNC uh what kind of
initiatives also do you have uh on he we
have a um for for type 2 diabetes we
have a we have chosen to try to attack
type 2 diabetes we have a a therapy that
is that is um growing around the world
very rapidly it's called a dpp4
inhibitor and it's an oral drug that you
can take once a day to control blood
sugar diabetes though is an exploding
problem and it's not just in the US
anymore it's also in even in Emerging
Markets China I don't know if you know
this but China has 60 million diabetics
this it's like the population of the UK
um so it's no it's no longer a disease
of developed um of the developed World
in hepatitis we have some very early
programs that are in drug Discovery we
have a a a a drug right now that we sell
in China called saivo for Hepatitis B
but for Hepatitis C we're in the very
early stages and there are many other
companies though that are that are
really addressing hepatitis
C is saying cpg in the cpg industry to
distribute your drugs or are there ways
that different Industries can work
together in order to solve The Last Mile
Challenge there there are you know one
of the things that we found in our
malaria initiative is that when you're
you're in a rural clinic and let's say a
woman has walked for two colet with her
child to go to that Rural clinic 25% of
the time they're out of stock so can you
imagine walking uh to a rural health
clinic and your child is sick and then
getting there and there's no quartum so
we worked with um a number of companies
to develop a program called SMS for life
and what we were finding is that these
rural health clinics because there was
not a lot of good uh coordination
between product Supply and the
distributor they didn't know when they
were going to be out of stock so we had
every one of the rural health clinics uh
just send an SMS at the end of the day
and talk about their um stocks so how
much stock did they have and it all went
into a central distributor that we had
and we were able to uh then have a much
greater fulfillment because everybody in
Africa has a cell phone it's like what
we did is we said look we don't need a
computer system to solve this Logistics
issue we're going to solve it with the
existing technology and so a simple SMS
allowed us to reduce the out of stock
level um from that 25% down to less than
5% and that was through a collaboration
with um a number of different
companies yes
go
ahead lot
about we also mention about the business
perspective I wonder how these two lces
business uh L and also Mission L
interact uh in your decision Mak you
made now it's a very good question right
how does a moneymaking company or an
entity that is that has shareholders
that demand a certain return also have a
very very mission that sometimes goes
against that that not against but is
maybe inconsistent at sometimes well we
are uniquely Swiss which means we have a
very long-term view I'm I I have the
privilege of having a board of directors
that tells me not to look at quarterly
earnings if you can imagine that being
an American you're pretty much trained
to look at quarterly earnings and to
think about that but we are we are
building the business the long term now
that mission is the core of what we do
so caring and curing is what we do which
means we're going to continue to spend
10 billion dollar a year on research and
development and sometimes my
shareholders yell at me and they say
look what I won't use the name of the
company look what they're doing they're
cutting their R&D and they're laying off
all their research and development
people and then I say but look at their
pipeline their drug pipelines are going
to not be strong in the next next five
years you can cut it one year two years
but you can't continue to do that and
have a good pipeline so we are investing
at the very high end of the industry and
it's a balance you have to say yes we
have shareholders that invest I listen
to our shareholders that are long-term
holders I do not listen to our
shareholders who are day
Traders yes uh can you explain the
rational behind focusing on insourcing
while other Pharma companies are trying
to look at alternative avenues for
accelerating drug Discovery and
development yes you have to draw a clear
distinction between cutting research and
development and Outsource and what is
right now called Outsourcing to try to
meet short earnings goals with actually
looking for new technology so even
though we are I wouldn't say insourcing
but we do a lot of our research inhouse
we are looking constantly for
new technologies that are emerging and
we will incense those so we generally I
try to keep our portfolio at
75% internally generated projects and
25% projects that come from the outside
now I think that's a very different
strategy and just the reason why we do
that is that we've spent a lot of money
building this capability and I look at
metrics and right now novaris has a
track record of launching new medicines
that's about about twice as good as the
average Pharma company so our success
rate if you go from phase one through
launch is actually twice as high as the
average Pharma company so I say we're
getting a pretty good return on that
investment so I'm going to continue to
invest but that doesn't mean um not look
at outside Technologies we still do that
also how are you segmenting the subs
Africa for non-
generic uh that's a good question we are
obviously offering all of our Innovative
drugs to um to anyone who needs them in
in Africa we have a number of patient
assistance programs but there's not a
huge market today for Innovative
medicines that are not reimbursed
because when you see the large
percentage that is out of pocket you see
that there there are there are um there
are not going to be patients that can
afford afford it so we have what we call
Patient Assistance programs where we
essentially give the drug so for example
we're famous for this India case with
our glec drug this chronic M leukemia
drug that I talked about that has a
patent in every Market in the world
except India and we drove um and I
pushed very hard to take that India
would not Grant a patent for for GC and
they said it was for um for patient
access you they wanted it they didn't
want to Grant a patent so that there
could be generic so there could be
patient access but that's that's just
not right because we get we give away
95% of all of the glec in India we give
it away free through this patient
assistance program and that wouldn't
have changed with a patent the
importance of a patent is that this is
how we ensure that medical science
continues to progress we because we're
engaged and I ask my shareholders to
engage in very highrisk activity and
that's Discovery and development of new
drugs we have to get a return for that
and we can only get it through
intellectual property so we push that to
a very very um hard hard level and many
people try to link that with access to
medicines but it really doesn't have
much to do with access because to to
your point about primary care and
how it's the primary care infrastructure
it's the number of Physicians the number
of nurses the the access to to cartum
that we can't even get to those Nations
it's not because of intellectual
property but that's a little bit about
the way that we think think of it yes
curious what the issues are with the
usfda and the menitis drug and why it
wasn't approved you for Princeton and
Santa Barbara we're working with them
very closely now that there's been an
outbreak for example we um the the you
know to give the US FDA credit they have
moved very recently towards a much more
Progressive look at new drugs so under
piggy hamburg's leadership um the FDA is
is really proactive and taking a very
proactive stance in terms of bringing
new Innovative medicines to Americans
who need them yet at the same time this
was a menitis B vaccine and menitis B is
a deadly disease it can kill in 24 hours
and and yet there W there was a lot of
discussion and debate about exactly the
clinical trial program that would have
to be done done to be able to get that
drug approved in the US now we have
extensively tested the vaccine and we've
tested it all over the world and it's
been approved in in many countries in
the world but the US still had certain
issues that they wanted to see us test
with this vaccine that weren't tested in
previous um and I I won't go into the
details but the the vaccine has been
proven safe and effective over many
years um so now that there is an
outbreak I think we do have the
opportunity to sit down with the FDA and
say can you look at the the uh European
data package that we've that we have put
together and then have a discussion
about it whether there are ways to
accelerate that into the us because I'm
an American and the fact that that if I
had a child or a grandchild that
couldn't get vaccinated but could get
vaccinated in Germany I I wouldn't like
it
yes
I was wondering because maybe the
efforts are so fragmented do you ever
are you ever concerned about any
redundancies in resolving these Health
Care issues I think we have to work with
Partners so if if you're absolutely
right in that everybody's looking at
Africa and saying we're going to invest
so also if you think about those Health
Care issues those aren't going to be
solved by one company at all so we're
thinking about how do we work with the
World Health Organization so our malaria
initiative is is a good example of how
we're working together so it's a good
point and the one of the issues is when
you have competitors sometimes the
competitors don't like to work together
but if you have other types of companies
like you have a technology company that
that can deliver a certain type of of
benefit together with a Pharma company
and also a Distribution Company you
could really create um some big solution
and there's other countries uh
particularly within Emerging Markets
where that's beginning to be a problem
for Pharma companies like Brazil for
example so how are you guys thinking
about working within markets such as
Brazil and India which are obviously
huge markets um they are huge markets
and right now I have said publicly that
we won't do research in India we will do
we we have a very large Center in
hydrabad where we do financial reporting
and we do some Analytics around
marketing and we do a lot of back office
support but we won't do research because
of the stance on intellectual property
it's very interesting because China gets
it um China wants to build a
science-based industry in China and what
you have seen is that government has
made in the last five years great
progress on protecting intellectual
property it's easier for easier for us
to get a patent now in China than was
five years ago and it's easier for us to
enforce patents if there's an attack on
our patent in China and in response to
that we're building a very large
research and development site in
Shanghai it's costing us over a billion
dollars but that that's the difference I
think between China and India in terms
of the understanding of the fact that
this is the way that that life sciences
can invest in in coming up with
breakthrough therapies it just doesn't
happen if there's not protection of
intellectual
property are there products within the
novaris portfolio that you've opted not
to pursue even attempting to launch in
the country period based off of other
challenges in the supply chain like C
change storywise yes um so there are
some vaccines that we have in our
vaccines division that unfortunately we
can't launch into India because of not
India into sub in Africa because of the
lack of cold chain distribution and
ensuring that we're going to have
quality assurance so that's another
example of how infrastructure itself not
access to medicines or vaccines but its
infrastructure keeps some of the
products off the market so as we start
to develop and we build we think that we
can solve a large part of those and it's
really commendable how the companies
with the in Innovative drugs how the
compan is trying to tackle but I was I
was wondering like through these social
responsibility initiatives are you also
looking at tackling the reason for such
high occurrence like instead of you know
doing uh cure like more like preventive
that why is it so high 91% in Africa no
it's very it's a very interesting uh
thing you know the Gates Foundation I
sit on the uh the CEO round table with
Bill Gates and a number of other Pharma
Executives and um there's a guy at Gates
by the name of Trevor Mandell and he
runs the health the public health uh
side of The Gates Foundation he they're
actually going to
test complete ER eradication of malaria
in a particular area by prophylactically
giving everyone cartum because the life
cycle of a mosquito is so short that if
you can if you can treat everybody in a
particular dis in a particular area over
a o over a it's actually a I think it's
a 29 day cycle you could potentially
eradicate the disease in that um in that
area so we are starting to think about
how the in terms of why we know why it's
because the disease is is prevalent in
terms of the the temperature and the
conditions but and there's and there's
people who are attempting spraying and
there's there's a lot of go trying to go
after the root cause of the problem and
there's also just some Innovative
thinking around how we could potentially
eradicate the disease so the question is
have you learned anything in other
developing markets that will help in
subsaharan Africa
about seven years ago when I went into
the Pharma division we had a um growth
rate in China that was only 5% and yet
the market in China was grow 20% because
what was happening is the middle class
in China was growing so fast and the
government was starting to reimburse at
a level that was much better than than
what it had done in the past that um
that we were not getting a share of that
and we looked very hard at why and the
answer was that we did not have an
integrated program yes we might have
hired more salespeople and we said oh we
can take our 5% up to 10 just by hiring
more sales people and that was not right
we had to go in with Physicians we had
to go in with research and development
money we had to do local manufacturing
so it's essentially the plan that you
saw here is the plan that we initially
did in China that has led to China
becoming one of our biggest markets so
we're taking the lessons that we learned
um many years ago and applying it here
so I I was wondering how do you see this
collaborative efforts evolving like when
it and when it comes to working with
comp competition and where do you draw a
line yeah that's a very good question I
don't know the answer well what I would
say is I would
say if you take this company's mission
of caring and curing there's
collaboration that we must do with
competitors or else we're not going to
be able to deliver our
mission so you're seeing companies like
novaris now start to collaborate with
competitors we have we're we're testing
with fizer and with two other of our
competitors a um a way to actually
improve access to medicines in uh the
Philippines that is a a unique and uh
varied approach that we've never taken
before and yet we're doing it with
competitors you have to be very careful
because from an antitrust standpoint if
it looks like you're working with a
competitor to increase access to
medicines in many places that can get
you into trouble so you have to bring
the lawyers along uh to every meeting
and and deciding what what we can do and
what we can't do in the market but in
terms of where to draw the line I think
it's it again comes back to that balance
we have people who invest their money in
our company and they expect us to be
able to grow our sales and our earnings
at a certain level or we're not going to
be able to attract their Capital another
company will will will um get their
Capital so it's my responsibility to be
able to balance the um corporate
responsibility efforts and how much we
spend on that with also the ensuring
that we're getting a return for the
money we're not really thinking about
Africa as as a uh highly Innovative
Market we're starting with over the
counter drugs and we're starting with
our generics um because the uh the
patent regimes have not matured yet
those economies are such that as they
start to grow and they they want to
attract more business and they
understand that protecting intellectual
property will be important then you
start to see the uh things that are put
in place like courts in those countries
that can help us defend our patents or
also just the ability to get a patent in
those countries so that we expect that
to happen over time but we're not
waiting for that we're going in with our
generics business because we think that
will be a big opportunity some companies
think about developing countries as an
opportunity to test new technologies
that may be not be feasible in the US
for regulatory reasons because
infrastructures here because of
interests like if you want to make set
up for example a an artificial
intelligence system that does diagnosis
and prescription without a physician you
wouldn't want to do that in the US it
wouldn't be feasible so I was wondering
um if you could explain a little about
how you see you know digital Health
digital Health what is going to
be happening in digital Health in the
third world as well as in the US um I
would say that we first of all to answer
your question the first part of question
we have one standard ac across the globe
so we will not do a trial in Africa that
we would not do in the US that's the
first answer to that question but the
but digital health I see as a massive
massive uh element to changing healthc
care in the developed world and in the
developing world all you have to do is
look at what's crushing our health care
System think about the fact that in the
US we spend 18% of GDP and we have worse
outcomes in terms of infant mortality
life expectancy then Singapore which
only spends three and a half% of GDP
this is unbelievable so so for and if
you think about what's driving that part
of it is just inefficiency in the system
right the world the developed World
spends over $4 trillion do in healthare
and we believe that 25% of that is
wasted either a a a pill is given to
somebody who's not going to respond to
it or people with heart failure come out
of the hospital they go back into the
hospital they come out of the hospital
so digital health I think will enable us
one easy example is remote patient
monitoring you can now give a remote
patient uh uh a monitor to a patient
that will monitor uh heart rate it will
monitor blood pressure it will monitor
things that we were not able to measure
before and we'll we'll be able to keep
patients at home until they really need
to come to the hospital and we'll be
able to reduce the the waste of um some
of the waste that is occurring right now
so there's there's an explosion of
technology in developing and developed
worlds in the developing world the thing
about technology is that you can leap
from right you don't have some of the
old infrastructure that you have in the
West in Western Europe or in the US like
the fact that everybody's got a mobile
phone so mobile Health in Africa is
going to be probably faster than in the
US
yes years in an emerging country or area
like Subs Africa how are you going to
control counterfeit drugs and drugs that
are being given after they theyve
expired for example yeah counterfeiting
is a big issue because it's very easy to
make a lot of money if if some somebody
who has no you know the somebody who
wants to counterfeit drugs in a country
where there are not good checks and
balances we have a as a company we have
a very large and strong security force
that spends a lot of time investigating
they're they're kind of underground so
you don't hear a lot about them but they
are constantly investigating counter
drugs of novaris in in Africa but even
in the US there are parts of the US
where there there sometime can be an
issue it's mostly outside the US but I
think the way to address it is to First
recognize that it's an issue and then
secondly put Technologies in place that
can prevent it so the whole industry is
about to invest in this technology
called track and Trace that from the
very um beginning of the production of
one drug you will be able to identify
through a basic scan where that drug was
produced whether it was the original
drug or not and what the expiration date
is and you'll be able to do this in a
way that we've never been able to do
before but we had to get to standards
across the whole industry so it's
recognizing the problem and then
investing in technology to fix it
yes R&D and bringing that on Shore but I
was also interested in just how you see
computational methods and how uh
throughput drug screening and how just
the evolution of drug Discovery has been
changing and Drug Discovery is on the
verge of an incredible I think
Renaissance when you think about big
data and and you think about the fact
that deep sequencing of the human genome
is so easy and it's so cheap we have a
very large oncology business and we are
now deep sequencing everyone uh every
with the patient's consent every tumor
type every oncologist patient that we
have it's creating an explosion of data
now we're also though building a
bioinformatics capability in our
research organization that can help us
make sense of this data but think about
the ability to link genetic mutations
multiple genetic mutations not just one
or two but multiple genetic mutations in
terms of understanding disease and
disease Target so I personally believe
that it's going to change the way that
drugs are discovered and you're going to
see in the next 10 years breakthroughs
that we haven't seen in a long time you
also mentioned earlier on that you guys
have a big generics business and that's
what you're going to push for in
subsaharan Africa at what point is nois
says that okay we've had this drug
patented for about 10 15 years we've
been reaping the profits and now maybe
we'll pass it on to our generic version
and pushing that out uh is that changing
currently and given the international
communities move towards using more
compulsory licenses and non-voluntary
licenses would novaris be be more
willing to either produce their own
generics or pursuing like negotiations
in order to receive more yes many people
ask us how we can have a an Innovative
Pharma Division and at the same time
have a generics division because they
say aren't those two things incredibly
inconsistent and I say they're
absolutely consistent we are
fundamentally Pro patent because that's
how Medical Science advances you have to
have patents for us to invest in
breakthrough new cancer drugs for
example but we also believe that the day
that that patent expires so we're not
asking for any more than the patent
period the day that it expires It's Our
obligation to offer lowcost highquality
generic versions and so we give it
immediately to our generics division so
for the example in um India that was a a
patent that we never received ever so we
wouldn't be asking to extend a patent we
don't want to extend a patent all we
want is that that period that we think
we need so that we can continue to
invest other questions yes I think we
have a time for maybe one or two yes
what worries you most about leading the
company into the future what worries me
the most
um I would say thinking about Health
Systems around the world right if you
look at what's happening the Aging
population is going to lead to um demand
for health care in the next 20 years
that is going to be significantly more
than than it is today and yet there are
governments around the world that cannot
pay for health care and I don't mean
Pharmaceuticals I mean hospitals
Physicians nurses so one of the things
that worries me is how is novaris going
to be part of the solution around Health
Systems not just transaction of selling
the pill but delivering a positive
outcome for Health Systems so that we
can lower the total cost of expense
Pharmaceuticals are only 10% of the cost
of healthare many people think it's 50%
but it's really the infrastructure cost
that we have to we have to address lower
costs for health care or else we're all
going to be in trouble because these
governments are just not going to be
able to to take care of the people as
they age so that's really the biggest
thing that I worry about listen it was
great to be here I want to thank
everybody for coming and good luck as
you continue your
studies